what is your paper about
to find an answer to this question you
first have to consider the following
question as well
first and foremost is what you want to
write about worth it
in other words you have to ask yourself
the so what test
what will be the contribution of the
paper to this field you're interested in
if you write this paper what will change
in the way academics see the field
what will you bring to the table that
hasn't been said before in those terms
to answer this question you have to
build your literature review
the core elements in an academic paper
it will be tantamount to know what your
contribution
may be to your field of interest the
second question is with whom should i
discuss in order to make sure that you
pass the so what test
how do you ensure that you pass the so
what test
this part is as scientific as it is
political
you have to be sure that the vocabulary
that you use in the frame of your
proposition will be coherent with the
way the reviewer will make sense of the
issue you're raising
to ensure that identify colleagues and
member of your network that can help you
position the paper in the terms that you
have chosen
finally the third question you have to
ask yourself is
what kind of paper do you want to write
academics paper can have different goals
whether your goal is theoretical
empirical or a methodological one
the design of the paper will be
different as the contributions and aim
of these papers are different
so will be the setting the methodologies
and the research
question your contribution will be
impacted by this
orientation for instance if you're
looking to publish in medical journal
for example like the new england journal
of medicine
which is oriented toward clinician as
well as researchers
the journal will not be looking for the
same contribution as a pure biological
oriented journal for example nature or
cell
all these questions and elements are
linked to your research question
the research question is the main
question raised in your paper
and the one you bring elements of answer
to in the paper
in short you have to understand the
field you're researching in
know what you can contribute to it and
know how to communicate your
contribution to this academic community
you have to position your paper so that
the community of researchers you are
specialized in the theme you have chosen
will accept it
many researchers struggle when it comes
to writing literature review for their
research paper
a literature review is a comprehensive
overview of all the knowledge available
on a specific topic till date
when you decide on a research topic
usually the first step you take in the
direction of conducting research is
learn more about the previous research
published on the topic
and this eventually translates into
literature review when you write your
research paper
literature review is one of the pillars
on which your research idea stands
since it provides context relevance and
background to the research problem you
are exploring
literature review essentially involves
two steps
surveying and critically reading the
existing literature
this step is commonly referred to as
experimental literature review
summarizing and actually penning down
the gist of your review in an organized
manner
this is known as theoretical review
literature review could be a part of a
dissertation or research article
and a standalone literature review let
us look at this in more detail
every research report thesis or research
article begins with an introduction to
the topic of research
this forms the literature review for the
article
the main purpose of the review is to
introduce the readers to the need for
conducting the said research
a literature review should begin with a
thorough literature search
using the main keywords in relevant
online databases such as google scholar
pubmed
etc once all the relevant literature has
been gathered
it should be organized as follows
background literature about the broad
research topic to introduce the readers
to the field of study
recent progress on the study topic which
can be organized thematically or
chronologically
ideally separate themes should be
discussed in a chronological manner to
describe how research in the field has
evolved over time
and to highlight the progress in the
field the review should include a
comparison and contrast of different
studies
discussing the controversial aspects
helps to identify the main gaps that
need to be worked upon
this is essential for defining the
problem statement of the study and
highlighting the significance of the
research under question
once a problem statement has been
defined the strengths and pitfalls of
other studies that have tackled the
problem statement should be discussed
this is important for outlining the need
and novelty of the research
a literature review should not be a mere
recounting of all the available
information
it should be a critical and analytical
summary of the selected literature that
guides the readers through the central
theme of the research
literature reviews can also be written
as standalone articles
these are not different from the
literature review sections described
above
however they are not followed by
experimental data
they basically fall into two broad
categories narrative reviews
and systematic reviews
narrative reviews are theoretical
discussions of relevant information on a
particular topic
and its critical analysis these are
mostly qualitative in nature similar to
the reduced sections of larger articles
narrative reviews are usually organized
as follows
introduction that establishes the
context of the field of research and the
topic of the review
body is normally used for describing the
different themes under the main topic by
dividing them into different subheadings
this section compares and contrasts
published studies and identifies gaps
that have not been addressed or have
been unsuccessfully addressed
conclusions this section differs
slightly between reviews which are part
of research articles
and narrative reviews the section
describes the main conclusions from
analysis of all the current studies
and puts forth further avenues for
research
this section requires critical
interpretation by the author such that
the review adds value to existing
literature
it should bring out ideas and hypotheses
that can explain any discrepancies
and provide solutions to existing
problems
systematic reviews on the other hand
follow a well-planned methodology to
qualitatively or quantitatively analyze
a defined number of studies
they usually focus on a single question
and have clear study objectives that are
worked upon in a systematic manner
these studies are based on a
well-defined strategy unlike narrative
reviews
systematic reviews and narrative reviews
are organized
slightly differently the details are
described below
introduction systematic reviews begin
with specific research questions that
are defined in terms of the samples and
research outcomes to be studied
methods these studies have a
comprehensive methodology that starts by
narrowing down the literature for the
review
usually specific inclusion and exclusion
criteria
are set based on the research questions
and databases are searched based on
these criteria
once the sample studies have been
shortlisted they are analyzed in detail
results the results section for these
studies involves comprehensive data
analysis to determine the significance
of the study outcomes
systematic reviews can be accompanied
with meta-analysis
which involves statistical analysis of
the included studies to increase the
power of the results
and discussion this section usually
interprets the study data based on their
weighted significance
and the power of the results the study
therefore
provides strengthened results that are
validated by the scientific rigour of
the analytical method
before starting to write a review it is
important to determine what kind of
review you want to write and follow the
appropriate style and guidelines
an effective literature review is
important for the complete life cycle of
a research from defining the right
research goals to correctly interpreting
and presenting the research results
let's assume that during the process of
literature review
you have to clearly identify the gap but
how to concretely fill it
you have mapped your scientific
literature after laborious work of
detection reading
writing you have depicted out the
problem you want to resolve
or at least make a contribution to the
literature that has already been studied
by the researcher in your community
then you think it will be interesting to
further the research around this
question which needs more investigation
and this is what we call the gap it's
not a matter of has it already been done
but is it possible to go further in this
direction in an original way
for example you should maybe never write
that it has never been done before
because the reviewer will tell you that
maybe there was a reason or it's just
not interesting
so now you are aware of this you must
explain in your article how you can
really contribute to the scientific
community by filling the gap in the
literature
we define it as a blank theoretical
space that you really hope at least
partially to fill thanks to your paper
the logical way to accomplish this after
presenting your gap
is to explain your objectives and how
you want to fill this gap
the first step will be to present your
research question
the research question of your article
will be the most important sentence of
your article
because it will make the links between
the gaps you will define and how you
propose to fill it
the research question is the keystone of
your paper
it has to be clear precise and concise
but not too general
if someone asks what is your article
about and sum it up in a few words
the white line research question should
be the answer
it should be the one sentence tracking
out your paper